hey guys i'm ryan right hi I'm Veronica
I just clicked on my camera I'm on the
phone the skype call with holy crap
okaasan you're getting this son
hockessin he has some popular reactions
out there I'm here today because he's
actually helping he's been the main
runner of this putting together reactor
mania reactor baby where a bunch of
hard-working reactors get together and
discuss stuff that we want to talk about
I'll be there hockessin leave him and a
few other people will be there they're
in the description box so yeah Gator
Martin won't be there I've met Gator
before he's a cool dude no disrespect
beginner WTF and it just for the record
just looking for a gator Martin he was
very interested and to be he was the one
of the big three betray myself you and
dinner from arden he's ready to go but
just for whatever reason this weekend's
not working out something's going on so
next time I'm sure I heard he I heard on
Sundays he stays in and masturbates all
day I didn't I understand I have no
objection to that you're watching this
gainer I know that's a truth Tamra
Magnus isn't gonna be there but I heard
you mention me in a video the popular
Tyrone Magnus mentioned me in a video
for like a second so Tyrone knows who I
am and bjs between the two of us Tyrone
if you're watching I can easily kick
your ass look at us look at your body
and then look at mine I take you down no
problem what is a boot camp yeah mention
my name I just want to hear him say my
name all right or the channel's name
there you go
this back and ready to react you will
[ __ ] you talking to what's that in that
the sense I like that Africa hmm
changing some more appendix friendly I'm
saying so apparently we got another
vintage TV spot hopefully we see
suddenly ain't seen before by the way I
wanted to react to column Rangers I
actually did react to power rangers I
made the video I was in the middle of
uploading when I went to get the link to
post it for the video description box
you said it had been deleted not
available now because copyright what I
thought they'd probably because they
made a parody and I don't know man but I
wrote David Martin and really just said
look he senators he sent but he's a
[ __ ] liar cuz I didn't get that
goddamn email maybe he messaged the real
epic r.e.a.l water he would know I don't
spell Tyrone TI or tyro room I want
Tyrone to email me we all want I want
him I want him to tweet me a shirtless
photo I think he's willing to do that
for me you know just like Tyrone since
you're not gonna be part of reactor
mania or maybe you'll watch this I want
to be a part of it now baby yes I me a
shirtless photo with your chest boobs
bouncing Wow can you
in the demonstration yeah see Tara I've
seen your pecs but here's mine boom boom
boom oh well boom chicka Bow Wow Shh my
name is ryan right well check out
reactor mania 2 o'clock Sunday you all
listen boys look you're going to see
tomorrow two o'clock p.m. los angeles
california time you do the conversion
Wison be there Veronica will be there
and I will be there and a bunch of other
[ __ ] well what the only other thing i
will say other reactors that i don't
know because my channels obviously much
smaller than yours but if there are
reactors out there that are interested
in joining please contact ryan or myself
it will get you in the little chat room
as well contact hammer yeah okay contact
me I don't want to deal with that
alright cool really hey buddy i'm
looking forward to sunday there i'm
looking forward to sunday 2 i'm gonna in
this video bye